KARSTEN VON HOESSLIN:
At this stage,
I'd love to board a working
Taiwanese longliner to see what
they make of the murder videos.
But they rarely come
into Port Victoria,
and they're not
exactly keen to talk.
Instead, I've been invited
onto a local longliner.
It's smaller than
the Taiwanese ships.
How's it going, gentlemen?
But catches fish
in the same way.
Captain, how are you?
I'm fine, thank you.
Good, very good to see.
Longliners are named after
the long, thin line that often
stretches 60 miles behind them.
There are thousands
of hooks spaced
at intervals down the line.
But each fish has to be reeled
in by hand one at a time.
The catch on these
local longliners
is closely monitored.
But the foreign boats seem
to play by different rules.
How much control, realistically,
do you think the Seychelles has
over those boats?
Do they even ever come
into Port Victoria,
or do they just stay out
there and do what they want?
I believe a lot
of these boats are
flagged and licensed without
even calling in Port Victoria.
The observers in the
ports will never know
what's really being fished.
- They will never know, exactly.
You don't get access
to the logbooks
to know of their movements,
the catch per day,
hooks being set per day.
And you don't know
what's happening.
You hear that they are
offloading in whatever port.
And there has to be tons of
illegal activities going on.
KARSTEN VON HOESSLIN: Commercial
fishing boats are always
meant to register
their catch, to check
it conforms with their quotas.
But by transshipping their
load to another boat,
they can escape detection.
Their catch gets
mixed up with legally
caught fish and
appears legitimate.
This is known as
fish laundering,
and it cost the global economy
billions of dollars a year.
Our economies, our
livelihoods, and our food all
depend on our oceans.
Illegal fishing depletes
the world's fisheries.
KARSTEN VON HOESSLIN: Were
the longliners from the videos
into this sort of
racket, fishing
illegally in the Indian Ocean?